[Music]
you a Muslim absolutely all right
welcome to the platform man what's on
your mind um this uh soall Islamic
dilemma okay is
totally a coldblooded lie a coldblooded
lie no doubt about it w and I did not
stutter I'm coming right at
you I like it you use this you use this
ayat which is so ridiculous ay first of
all you said you was of
Quran no you're not but all due
respect
huh impossible then tell me the five
Revelations that almighty God Allah
speaks about in the Quran tell me the
five Abraham scriptures you got the
Torah the zabor the injil and the
Quran okay very
good very
good okay now um listen to me very
closely I'm listen you you you ask you
ask the question what is the
inal we ask that all the time yes do you
not all the time okay I can tell you
what is not the in jail for sure I bet
you can I I bet you can tell me what I
know what I know what you got is
definitely not the in you know what hold
that thought my brother hold that
thought let's go ahead and run our
little first what is the inil segment of
2025 ladies and
gentlemen welcome to another segment of
what is the NGL 2025 Edition this is the
first one of the year and we got our
first contestant of 2025 correct
understanding he tells us that I'm
always asking what the angil is but he
could for sure tell me what it's not go
ahead correct understanding give us the
correct understanding those five
Revelations that you so eloquently
mentioned okay Y what language was they
revealed in you the Quran doesn't
mention are you crazy
Avery Avery no idea to whom you talking
to those five Revelations were revealed
to
Semite men yeah what language though
Semite semetic languages semetic
languages semetic languages there are
wait is there only one semetic language
I didn't say that okay I'm saying to you
I'm saying to you I'm saying to you all
five of them was semetic language which
semetic language I can only name Hebrew
I could Aramaic and
Arabic where dides your Quran tell you
that any of those books was revealed in
any of those languages because Allah
tells us that the men that he gave these
books to okay when they went to the
people they those men spoke the language
of his people how do you know that it
was a semetic language that those people
spoke because all five of these men are
semites it is ridiculous to think it is
ridic
it is ridiculous to think know that
because they are Semitic Abraham was
Abraham was a Semite my brother how do
you know that because he was a Semite
does your Quran tell you that huh does
your wait a minute brother hold on let's
not be ridiculous now Abraham was a
Semite Jesus was a Semite wrong okay
David David was a Semite where does your
Quran say that okay I heard you where
does your Quran tell you that though it
does have to tell me that brother so all
five of them all five of these men were
semites where do you get you can't get
out of that wait where do you get that
from huh what are you talking about we
know for a fact that Abraham Abraham
Abraham was a Semite you when you say
you know that for a fact where are you
getting that fact from from history
a okay let's let's let's look let's
let's breing it it's not the Bible
brother oh it's not it's not the Bible
I'm just digging where you're coming
from it's not the Bible so I'm G shut
that down I'm G shut that down at the
gate what history okay what history we
know that Noah is the father of shim
shim is the father wait you know Noah is
the father of shim where you get that
from okay we know that all through the
history what history okay oh my God
Avery all these men are citic men what
history no it's not the Bible a it's not
the Bible it's
encyclopedias
encyclopedias Google certain things you
know I got you Habibi I got you you got
the
encyclopedias what encyclopedia tells
you that that Noah was the father of
shim that these men were semetic okay
and where is the encyclopedia getting it
from okay hold on Avery you know
something you're doing very bad right
now you know why because you're sitting
up here actually leading your um your
people to believe that maybe these men
were not citic
really you know damn well they were
semites you know you know you know what
you you know good and well they were
semites ay you're not a dummy I've been
watching you for a long time you're not
a dummy let me let me just say this let
me just say this because I hear what
you're saying you're saying by me
challenging you on this it can lead
people to think that maybe these people
weren't semites however I think you're
looking at the glass half full half
empty you need to look at it half full
because the other perspective is is that
I'm actually doing really well and
you're doing bad because all I'm asking
you to do is to prove to me or give me
some evidence or a source for what
you're saying how you know and where you
getting these facts from about Abraham
about David about Jesus about Noah these
prophets that you're talking to that
you're talking about how do you know
these things about these people and when
you say you don't have the you're it's
not the Bible okay fine so then help us
out give us the source on how my
source my SCE the Quran oh yes it is oh
yes it is okay good so show oh yes it is
here it is show me where in the Quran it
tells you one let me just we'll start
slow show me where in the Quran it tells
you that Noah is the father of shim go
ahead that that uh that technically um
Allah does not mention that okay so now
okay good but now hold hold on please
because I don't want this I don't want
this to get out of hand okay we know
that the TR of Israel the B Israel were
semites how huh how what do you mean ay
you are trumping your face by asking
such a ridiculous question it is a
histor it is a historical fact they were
semites I get you what is the his why
are you doing that brother look look the
reason why I'm doing this is this
because you have come here and you have
come here very
confidently absolutely brother told me
that theil is not the Bible you know it
for a fact and no it's not it's not I
got you and that's ridiculous hold on
and that the historical facts that
you're stating about these prophets
don't come from the Bible it does not
have to come from the Bible so the
reason why I'm doing this is because I'm
showing you how you shot yourself in the
foot respectfully go ahead go ahead if
you're going to say it's not from the
Bible you got to give me something if
it's I'm saying I'm saying it's from the
Quran no you're not and I stand by that
and I stand by that and I'm not ashamed
of it but you just said that it doesn't
come from the Quran you just said that
hold hold I said to you that Noah being
the father of shim is not mentioned in
the Quran where is that mentioned I did
okay plain and simple where's okay but I
but I have studied the Jewish Scholars
Christian Scholars and Islamic scholars
yeah
okay hold on brother hold on wait a
minute the um uh you telling me that um
everything comes from the Bible my
brother are you telling me that just
just follow just follow don't ask me
what I'm telling you I'm not telling you
anything I'm only asking you where you
see but I want to destroy I want to
destroy your false notion that if it
comes from the Bible then I have to
believe in the entirety of the Bible
interrup me this whole time man I'm G
have to start muting I don't want to do
that let's keep a
flow you said that you studied the
Christians the Jews right and where they
get and the Islamic scholars brother
Islamic scholars where do they get it
from that Abra I'm sorry that Noah is
the father of shim where do they get it
from they get it from historical um let
me see um from the history that we know
of these men it's not necessarily the
Bible I will not I will never say that
and I will not and and I will not deny
that it may come from the
Bible understand I will not deny that
here's my question and this look you can
really just end this super easily just
tell me where do you get the history of
Noah and his sons where do you get it
it's not the it's not the Quran and
you're
saying hold on but wait a minute did I
not
outright outright say that the Quran
does not mention that didn't I say that
the quran's out no I'm not saying the
Quran is out I'm saying the Quran does
not mention that but when I when I
learned when I learned about Noah and
shim and uh the history of the children
of Israel and the history of the
children of Ismael it was not
necessarily the Bible brother I got you
you got okay and you need to stop that
ay you need to stop that got it from
teachers right who have studied these
sources right
absolutely um I've no Scholars
personally pay attention to my question
so you know how to deal with this my
question is these these people who
taught you these Scholars and in this
field what is their Source from where
they're getting the information from and
the history of Noah and his sons what's
their Source the Christian scholar the
the Islamic scholar the uh the Jewish
scholar the rabbi you know their source
for God intelligent like you what you're
doing right now is psychologically
ridiculous you know why I love you
because you know exactly what I'm saying
so cut your crap man cut it out quick I
don't appreciate for you to insult my
intelligence you know that these people
have a history and you know they're
Semitic people I know that you went on
you went on with the Noah and his sons
because I admitted no I noticed that
because I admitted to you that the Quran
does not State about Noah and his sons
can you just say that you don't know the
source about what about where it says
that Noah I can say this I can say this
that what I'm saying is historically
accurate based on what okay there was
semites Noah was not a Semite uh but
shim was my brother I I want to give you
a a a real chance but it sounds you're
not you're making it hard for me man I I
like how am I making it out I that I
like came to you and told you about the
five hold on dude you're talking over me
and I'm the host relax I had to mute you
because you probably don't even know
that you're muted you know I um I'm
having a good time with you I am I am
I'm I'm having a wonderful time with you
a but you're making it hard for me to
keep you here now okay because now we're
we're reaching the point where you talk
and you're loud but you have nothing to
present to me you know you you you're
not bringing you're not giving me
anything to work with okay you admitted
that it's not in your Quran that
mentions Noah as uh the the father of
Shem so where are you getting that from
you can't answer that you said it's not
the
Bible where is it then what's the source
that tells you that tells your Scholars
that tells your teachers that tells
these people who study this stuff what
is the source that gives them the
history
of Noah and his sons if you can't answer
that for me OG I'm going to move on to
the next
person okay I'm about to unmute you
now okay
um you muting me was very disrespectful
but I I I will tolerate it I will do
that thank you I appreciate it your
grace don't don't insult me uh uh uh
Avery I didn't insult have not don't
call me um your grace this is not a game
bro this is real we're trying to get
into heaven we're trying to get into
heaven brother all about your
highness okay see you're arrogant
young swine eting
Infidel you know what I assume Avery
because I've been watching you is that
you you read a lot how can I like this
guy I love him okay you know what I
assumed that when I made that statement
since you
are you read a lot whatever you have
some information that you would go with
the flow but now you're going to ask me
what is the source and everybody knows
that shim is the father of the semetic
langu uh uh
people why you telling me Oh Where did
they get it from come on that is a
distraction it's either you can give me
the answer that I'm looking for or you
can be honest and humble and say you
know what Avery I don't have that answer
for you man I can respect that but if
you continue to you know what I'm saying
to you what I'm saying to you this is
that I never learned it I never learned
it from the Bible now watch this okay I
never learned it from the Bible I've
been known about the Bible all my life
but where do you think that the people
who taught it to you got it from that's
the question I'm asking about the source
not not necessarily like how did you
hear about it I I I hear what you're
saying you know I I you you heard it
from people who know this stuff my thing
is because every it all goes to a
primary source you understand okay ay he
I'll break it down to you very
simplistic okay you ready it could be
their Source could be the Bible all
right nice okay I said they could be the
Bible got it so we'll go with this so
the source of Noah and his sons the
history of Noah and his sons and even
these people being semetic in the first
place is the Bible can we grant that no
I cannot agree with that because
Muhammad is not a Christian Muhammad is
not a Jew you understand Abraham is
mentioned in the
Quran AB Jesus is mentioned in the Quran
Jesus is mentioned in the Quran okay see
see this and that's a problem with that
too check that out but look notice this
the things that you're saying about
these characters you don't get from the
Quran this is the point you're pulling
from the Bible for your historical
information on Moses Jesus David and the
others this is the point while at the
same time rejecting the Bible you see
what see how silly that is brother no no
no brother you have to calm down Avery
I'm I have to teach you some things
that's not necessary true man Teach me
Teach me okay the Bible is not what you
think it is my brother it Tru isn't all
right if you were to crack the Bible and
go to the genealogy of Christ found in
Luke and Matthew why do they contradict
each other they don't it's just two
different geologies from two different
lines that's all two different lines you
got the legal you got the legal line of
of Joseph you got the legal line of
Joseph and then you have the uh the the
line of his of his of of Joseph's
brother basically because he takes on or
his father takes on um when he when his
brother dies when the brother dies you
know uh his brother steps up to give his
to continue his brother's line okay so
you have two different lines it's not
okay I never heard what you just said
you can find it in uus okay hold on it's
bogus why totally bogus as a Muslim as a
Muslim I will tell you outright that
Christ Jesus was born of the Holy Virgin
Mary where okay where in the Quran it
states that no I know that but where was
he born
though where was he born yeah he was
born in Palestine where did the tell you
that okay we know where he was born
Avery there you go again you're
distracting no there you go Avery stop
Avery stop it stop being disrespectful
paltin okay plain and simple stop that
Avery how do you know okay we know that
Jesus Christ was born in the so-called
Middle East in particular
um Bethlehem oh well
Bethlehem no say some some people
believe he was okay and then
um okay um and the other one is called
um how do you nasar yeah Nazareth how do
you know that but in the Arabic it's
nasara
um
okay far as what I don't understand why
you keep on asking me that for how do
you know that how do you know that he
was born in bethle and was and was
around and grew up in Nazareth how do
you know that Allah speaks about that
okay good show me where Allah tells you
that he was born in Bethlehem or or grew
no Allah does not say that
directly then why don't try don't try
don't try to put words in my mouth Avery
you just said Allah spy you have been
trained you have been trained by certain
people and you and and you're a damn
good student but those clowns that train
you are pure Devils
themselves do you understand me I
understand you OG look I'm gonna give
you the win today man I'm gonna go ahead
and move on to the next guest but I
appreciate you for coming thank you so
much Allah Lord bless you brother bless
you bless
you wow how can you not like a guest
like he's spirited he's
convinced and uh he makes you laugh man
he brings smiles to your face how can
you not love a man how can you know how
can you not love the Og
man oh man those Devils those snakes
those swine eating infidels
[Laughter]
[Music]